here in Germany new military recruits
are being sworn in on the 76th
anniversary of a plot to assassinate
Adolf Hitler the tradition reminds
members of the Armed Forces to be loyal
to their country rather than to a
particularly der on July 20th 1944 klaus
von Stauffenberg led a group of officers
who tried to kill Hitler with a
briefcase bomb Hitler survived the
attack and Stauffenberg and his
co-conspirators were rounded up many of
them were executed today klaus von
Stauffenberg is hailed by the German
German armed forces as a role model and
is honored in ceremonies around the
country well let's bring in our
political correspondent Nina Haase
with more on this story hi Nina good
morning tell us more about how this day
is being commemorated well this year
it's going to be commemorated in quite a
different way because of course the
corona virus is still a threat and
protective measures against the virus
are still in place here in Germany so
this year there will be no audience
present on the ground at that prison
where many of the people who took part
in that attempted assassination were
killed by the Nazis but there will be
some high-ranking German officials there
and there will also be the grandson of
Stauffenberg himself who will give a
speech and of course the German Defense
Minister is going to be there because of
the ceremony where the new recruits are
going to be sworn in what role do you
think this day plays in Germany's
collective memory today it is still
alive in Germany's collective memory of
course there have been books there have
been exhibitions there has been the
Hollywood film starring Tom Cruise and
the German government's over the last
few decades have tried actively to keep
that memory alive by commemorating that
event every year by also choosing that
date for that special ceremony where new
recruits are sworn in and the idea of
course is to ingrain that principle of
resistance against any form of fascism
right-wing extremism within modern-day
German soldiers having said that of
course the memory is also beginning to
fade somewhat according to recent polls
where some 15 years ago a poll found
that half of Germans didn't know what
that date stander stood for and
that number was even lower with a young
generation where one in four I had no
idea what about the way that Klaus von
Stauffenberg is perceived by Germans how
has that changed through the decades it
has changed tremendously and of course
that is very symptomatic and symbolic of
how Germans and different German
generations have thought of their
country's Nazi past right after the war
in the early 50s there was a poll that
found that some 60% almost of Germans
thought negatively of that attempted
assassination and it took younger
generations to question their parents
and grandparents activity during the war
during the Nazi era to change that
perception of what the Nazis had
actually committed which crimes that
committed and how that whole period was
seen in over the decades and then of
course these days a fraction of Germans
only think of Stalin Beck and his people
as traitors interestingly enough the
some members of the alternative for
Germany party which is of course
Germany's biggest opposition party call
Davin Beck and his people traitors and
that is proved to some experts that this
party is at least home to some people
with right-wing extremist views our
political correspondent Nina Haase thank
you very much a solemn trumpet salute
for the heroes of the German resistance
the pared-down ceremony was held at the
site of plesance a prison in berlin
where many of the conspirators were
executed after their plot to kill Hitler
had failed on the 20th of July 1944
German army officer Klaus von
Stauffenberg led the attempt to kill the
dictator with a briefcase bomb Hitler
survived the attack but the plot showed
the world that not all Germans back the
Nazis a story that still has meaning
today according to stauffenberg's
grandson it is a biblical truth that in
democracies there have been many
successful assassinations which have
changed the cause of the world in a
tragic way against dictators
assassinations have almost never
succeeded
but these resistance fighters resolved
that they must make the attempt whatever
the cost
Germany's defense minister stressed that
the example of the plotters continues to
inspire the country's military we will
empower peace freedom and humane this
around the world
we were knew this promise here and now
in commemoration of the men and women of
the 20th of July 1944 a different manner
thus 116 early to underline that
tradition the 20th of July is now a date
when German army recruits swear their
oath of allegiance to serve their
country but also to put their conscience
above mere obedience to orders in
another world war 2 commemoration France
has been marking the Nazi roundup of
thousands of Parisian Jews in July 1942
they were taken into custody in an
operation known as Velda yves named
after the cycling racetrack where most
of them were first held only a limited
number of people were allowed to attend
the ceremony because of copán 19
precautions this was a very controlled
environment where even the children of
survivors could not attend but the
significance of the ceremony loomed
large it commemorates the events of July
1942 when more than 13,000 Paris Jews
were rounded up by the German occupying
forces with the help of French police
most of the Jews were brought to the
city's indoor cycling track they and the
others were then deported to the
Auschwitz concentration camp at the
ceremony a leader of the Jewish
community in France expressed his
concern about the rise of anti-semitism
there was an almost 75 percent increase
in anti-semitic acts in the country in
2018 and a further increase of more than
25 percent last year the mayor of Paris
Anadarko said she's concerned just with
hey there you go see good
I would also like before the end of this
year if health conditions allow to
organize with all the religious and also
secular authorities a conference to take
a moment to reflect on and review all
these foundations of anti-semitism and
racism undermining our society human and
local society more than 75 thousand
French Jews were deported to Nazi death
camps but only a few thousand survived